and now Tamsin Greig in terms of acting
and acting tips you was it gremlin and
who made black books he wrote directed
black books yeah and he gave me the best
piece of direction that I've ever been
given I was in a scene where I was in
bed listening to the radio because the
voice of the man reading the shipping
forecast really turned me on this is the
work I do yeah so I was in bed and I had
to be being turned on and I was getting
slightly embarrassed and shy I was
pregnant I was feeling mad as you are
and Graham came over to and he said him
okay the noises that you're making could
you could you make the noises that you
might make getting into a hot bath and
that that was it I was like
there are going to be so many suspicious
husbands tonight just thinking how can I
sound familiar
getting into a hot bath was very lazy if
you're getting a long time when they act
like they're getting into a cold bath
with me
I tell him don't call me grandpa cuz
every time in it's hilarious cuz he'll
he'll just keep doing it because bothers
me I say don't call me grandpa and he'll
go grandpa every time he calls me and I
get a little older